the only problem with hillary's  statement here is that it is  completely incorrect as even fbi  director james comey a man who certainly  is not fond of donald trump and has made  that perfectly clear admitted  at the time  from the group of 30 000 emails returned  to the state department in 2014  110 emails  in 52 email chains have been determined  by the owning agency to contain  classified information eight of those  chains contained information that was  top secret 36 of those chains contained  secret information and eight contained  confidential information at the time  in other words hillary stored lots of  classified documents than trump in a  much less secure location than trump  without any of the right to do it as  trump since unlike trump hillary was  never the president of the united states  and therefore never had ultimate  authority to declassify information